Komm mit ins Podcast-Dom vorhinein mit Flo und Stefan Tietze hereinspaziert, nimm dir einen Keks, wir steigen ein, mit der Nacht getrubelt, Mathis und dir, Florentin Will. Danke, rockig, rockiges Intro heute von Tobi, da spitzt sich doch mein Kleiner und mein Zeigefinger zum Teufelsraum. Tobi hat den Verstärker angemacht, den Verzerrer angeschmissen, den Volume-Tuner auf Anschlag gedreht, lehnt sich so ein bisschen nach vorne und singt in das Mikrofon rein, noch ein bisschen, lehnt sich hinein, stützt sich auf dem Monitorbox ab und singt zum Publikum, kommt hereinspaziert. Und Rock'n'Roll lebt. Also viele sagen ja, Rock'n'Roll ist tot. Ja, wurde gerade wieder überlebt von Tobi auf jeden Fall. Aber Tobi hat selber selbstständig die Schaufel in die Hand genommen. Punk ist tot. Rock'n'Roll hat man, glaube ich, lange nicht mehr gesehen einfach. Punk ist tot? Nee, Punk is dead, Rock'n'Roll gilt als vermisst, glaube ich. Was mit Disco? Disco ist schon seit den 70ern, darf man das gar nicht mehr sagen, glaube ich. Mit New Wave in den 80ern und so ist man Disco komplett abgelöst. Falls ihr Rock gesehen habt, meldet euch. Ja, bitte. Wir vermissen Rock sehr, reißt euch einen kleinen Zettel ab, da steht eine Telefonnummer drauf, ruft an, helft uns. Und schickt uns keinen Spotify-Link, weil das ist nicht der Sinn der Sache. Nee, Rock'n'Roll ist dann nur konserviert. Rock'n'Roll will never die, but maybe go lost someday. Maybe go lost in Argentina, glaube ich. Das war damals das Versprechen von Motorhead und so ist es dann auch gekommen. Motorhead? Motorhead. Motorhead-hae. Das sind diese Wörter mit diesen ganzen Punkten obendrauf, wo man so ein bisschen all in
gehen muss mit der Aussprache.
Ja, ja, wo man sich aus Deutschland auch immer getriggert fühlt, denkt man, oh, was
ist das denn für eine, ist das nicht ein Umlaut, nein, ist das nur ein Stilmittel, ist nur
Logo.
Ja.
Ist es noch umlaut oder ist es schon Logo?
Weiss ich nicht, aber es ist natürlich eine gute, weil es sieht natürlich witzig aus
für andere Sprachen, so Punkte obendrauf, sieht ja aus wie so ein Smiley.
Sieht lustig aus.
Ich habe manchmal Phasen, wo ich das kleine Ö immer als A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A-A- irgendwie Köln oder so und lese immer K. K. Köln, Köln, K. Ja, es ist eigentlich, wie man aussieht, wie man Köln sagt. Köln, Hallöle. Sind so die Buchstaben entstanden, wie das Gesicht aussieht, wenn man den Buchstaben macht? K, P. Beim K hast du ja auch den Mund so weit auf. K. Ist K nicht so ein von der Seite gemalter Mund, der O aufgeht? Beim kleinen L hat man so die Zunge, die Zunge wird lang. Die Zunge wird zum L. Lang, stimmt, lang ist ja auch eigentlich onomatopoetisch. Gibt es denn onomatopoetische, potetische, potetopoetato, gibt es denn Wörter, die onomatopoetisch sind? Ja, aber eine ganze Menge. So, meinst du die so klingen, sie sind das was Krachen. Krachen klingt wie Krach. Das kannst du lautmalerisch sagen. Ist deutsch lautmalerischer als Englisch zum Beispiel? Es ist auf der lautmalerischen Skala kurz hinter Finnisch, aber noch vor Chinesisch. Vor Chinesisch, vor Englisch auch wahrscheinlich? Ja, Englisch geht eigentlich. Smash, Slash, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh ist wie der Gitarrist. Aber Swoosh ist gut, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Swoosh, Nur echt, wenn man den Tunneleffekt auch nachmacht, äh, den Doppeleffekt. Ja, stimmt. Aber nein, es ist eine faszinierende Sache. Wir haben tatsächlich, als wir letztens die Frage gestellt haben, gibt es eine Sprache nur mit positiven Begriffen, hat sich natürlich jemand gemeldet, vielen Dank an die Sprachwissenschaftler, und hat uns darauf hingewiesen auf das, ich nenne es mal, Sprachprojekt Esperanto. Sprachprojekt? Du machst es kleiner. Du machst es kleiner. Sprachagil. Nee, die Sprachgruppe. So, jetzt kommt die Sprachgruppe. Jetzt kommt der Sprachkurs. Was habt ihr überlegt? Wir haben uns überlegt, eine Sprache mit möglichst wenig Wörtern, und dann gibt's die Vorsilbe mal, das heißt dann, dass es schlecht ist, so dass alle Begriffe man nur einmal machen muss. Ach so, okay. Also statt schlecht sagt man mal gut. Wenig weniger schlecht gut. Und sagt hässlich sagt man mal mal schön. Also halt immer so. Und das heißt, es gibt eigentlich alle normalen Stammwörter, sind nur positiv, aber mit mal kann man es dann negativ machen. Vielen, vielen Dank an den Einsender oder die Einsenderin, die uns darauf hingewiesen hat. Wie wurde die Mail formuliert, würde ich mir interessieren. Waren da viele schlechte Begriffe drin oder war da sehr mal? Also man hat schon gemerkt, dass Deutsch nicht die erste Sprache ist, sondern dass da jemand in Esperantonien auf... Hallo Flotin und Stefan, ich habe ewig gebraucht, um eure Mailadresse zu finden. Deswegen, ich bin so mal zufrieden mit der Situation, wie eure Mails, eure Mailadresse im öffentlichen Zugehörigen, könnte vielleicht mal verbessern.
Ja, aber man hat schon gemerkt, aber es waren viele interessante Formulierungen drin, aber hat funktioniert. Wahrscheinlich Zusendung aus Esperantosien. Tosenien. Freut mich, dass wir auch da Hörer haben. Wir haben ja immer eine Statistik, wo unsere Hörer herkommen. Und das finde ich immer sehr lustig, weil dieses Dokument immer 18 Seiten lang ist, wo man sich denkt, wow, intensive Datenanalyse, Statistik, Big Data. Nee, es ist überall einer. Genau, nee, es ist Deutschland 99 Prozent und an jedes Land der Welt. Auf dem mindestens ein Hörer sitzt. Mit einem Hörer. Und da hast du erstmal die ganzen afrikanischen Länder. Mein Gott, was hast du da für Länder? Tansania, Ruanda, Burkina Faso, Uganda, ja, da hast du ja unendlich viele allein in Afrika, alle eins. Und das hast du dann halt so wirklich so, wenn man das ausdrücken würde, wäre das wirklich so ein richtiger Packen, wäre das wow, Statistik, aber nee, alle Seiten sind nutzlos. Jedes Land steht da mit einem Hörer. Wir haben in jedem Land einen Hörer mindestens. Was verrückt ist, dass man nicht mal zwei in Schweden hat, nee, genau einer. Einen in Schweden nur? Nee, in Schweden stimmt mehr. Nee, nee, nee, Schweden finden alles eine einzige Person. Vielleicht müssen wir mal irgendwie so ein Konzil machen, dass alle zusammenkommen wie so ein UN-Parlament, wo alle so dann den Namen ihres Landes Vorsicht haben, der große Puffo wendt, wo dann wirklich alle zusammenkommen und sagen, so, wir müssen jetzt mal handeln. Also alle haben dann auch so ein Mikrofon und werden aber nicht übersetzt, weil alle sprechen ja die Sprache.
Genau, alle werden in Esperanto übersetzt und da muss man halt so gucken, wie weit man kommt im Verständnis. Wie man gucken, wie man klarkommt.
Ja, schau einfach, wie weit du kommst.
So, das ist wie wenn man als Nichtsprachler in einer Freundesgruppe ist auf einer Party und man sagt, wir werden nicht alles für dich übersetzen, guck halt, wie du klarkommt. Ja, schau einfach, wie weit du kommst. Das ist wie wenn man als Nichtsprachler in einer Freundesgruppe ist, auf einer Party, und man sagt, wir werden nicht alles für dich übersetzen, guck halt, wie du klarkommst. Ja. Und man dann einfach sagt, ja, ich verstehe halt nichts. Ja, kann ich irgendwo den Untertitel anmachen? Nein, okay, dann setze ich mich hierhin. Nee, die Flips verstehe ich auch so, werde ich mich halt um die kümmern den Rest des Abends und dann fett, man. Er hat Nüsse. Fett in kleine Würmchenformen gepresst und schmackhaft. Ja, und lest du die ganze Zeit die Packungsbeilage. Die Erdnuss fasziniert mich, vor allem die kulturellen Unterschiede der Erdnuss. Kann ja vielleicht mal jemand eine Studienarbeit schreiben darüber, weil mir ist letztens aufgefallen, Erdnussbutter ist in Deutschland unterrepräsentiert, vor allem was Schokoriegel angeht. Wenn du in Amerika bist, hat fast jeder Schokoriegel Erdnussbutter drin, immer.
Da hast du Take Five, Wonder Bar, die ganzen Sachen.
In Deutschland, klar, es gibt Snickers, aber Snickers hat keine Erdnussbutter, sondern die Erdnuss-Dieren.
Jetzt sind aber alle Reeses-Artikel rübergeschwappt.
Aber die setzen dich auch nicht hundertprozentig durch.
Reeses ist ein guter Punkt.
Die sind jetzt überall, nur kann man die kaufen.
In jedem Rewe, in jeder Tankstelle mittlerweile kann man überall Reese's kaufen, das ist ganz neu.
Ja gut, in Tankstellen kann man alles kaufen. Ich war letztens in der Tankstelle, es gab sieben verschiedene Beefy Bigs, nicht Beefys, Beefy Big und davon gab es nochmal sieben Stück. Ich ziehe meinen Salamihut, weil Beefy hat das wirklich alles durchgespielt.
Also Beefy hat vor allem auch Tankstellen ja erschlossen. Ja. Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn da irgendwann irgendwie Beefy, also Shell powered by Beefy oder so, einfach, oder wenn da Beefy tankst, weil die die Tankstellen gekauft haben. Ja. Weil die haben das ja so ein bisschen übernommen, die haben ja, also wie viele Rolls gibt es denn, XXL, XL, L, M, S, XS, Pocket, dann so eine Tüte mit so Beefy Bits halt wieder, dann Currywurst. Oh, Beefy Bits fände ich ja mega, Beefy Roll Bits fände ich super. Es gab doch mal diesen kleinen scheiß Plastikeimer mit Kugelwiener Würstchen. Wo ist der? Kugelwiener Würstchen Plastikeimer, stimmt, du machst da so einen Fass auf. Ich erinnere mich an die. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, wie die beworben wurden und ich dachte, holy crap, ich glaube das war das erste Mal, dass ich in den Supermarkt gegangen bin und aktiv nach dem Produkt gesucht habe und mir dachte, na vielleicht kommt es morgen. Also so wie wenn ein neues Zelda erscheint und man auf den Reelstag wartet. So war es bei diesen Wiener Würstchenbälchen. Noch besser finde ich, wenn die so Hotdog-mässig aussen noch so eine Brotschicht hätten. Ja.
Das als Eimer würde ich mich reinsetzen wollen. Ich glaube, irgendwie so Knackis oder irgendwie sowas in der Ecke hießen die. Vor allem, dann gab es noch die mit Käse drin. Das waren Wiener Würstchenbällchen mit Käsepocken drin, Käseinfiziert. Oh mein Gott. Gibt's nur in Deutschland und in Amerika. Nee, wir lieben die Flips. Wir lieben die Flipformen. Also es gibt ganz spezielle Formen, Erdnussbutter in Riegeln eher amerikanisch, Peanut Butter Jelly, ja, irgendwie die verschiedenen Riegeln, Reese's Pieces, aber Erdnuss Flips wieder nur in Deutschland. Ich glaube, da bräuchte man auch mal so einen Konvent. Eine Brücke. Ja, so United Peanut Nations. Wollen wir die Peanut-Brücke schlagen? Ich wäre aber sofort dabei. Weil ich glaube, da muss ein Austausch stattfinden,
dass man mal zusammen irgendwie sich an den runden Tisch setzt. Sicherlich können die Amerikaner
von den Deutschen viel lernen, was
die Flip-Manufaktur
angeht, wie man jetzt das
vernünftig in den Staat bringt und da irgendwie auch in
Amerika eine gesunde Infrastruktur
erbaut, um Flips
standardmäßig überall in die Läden zu bringen.
Auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich, können wir von den Amerikanern viel mehr lernen, die Erdnuss zu nutzen. Ohne Erdnussmesse starten, Ende des Jahres? Weil jetzt gerade sind ja eh die ganzen Messen verloren und haben, glaube ich, auch Existenzängste und so. Die Enumee? Da können wir jetzt doch die Enumee mal starten. Die erste deutsche Erdnussmesse? Finde ich eine gute Idee. Vor allem, also ich habe, irgendwie habe ich manchmal so, immer so Gedanken, so fast zwanghafte Gedankenbilder im Kopf, die ich nicht loswerde. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel so ein Glas Erdnussbutter sehe, denke ich mir, wie viele Erdnisse braucht man für ein Glas Erdnussbutter? Und dann, was passiert mit den ganzen Schalen? Da muss ja irgendwo ein riesiger Berg Erdnussschalen liegen, nur für aber wer knackt die? Wer knackt die? Und wer stellt hundertprozentig sicher, dass nicht in den Schalen noch irgendwo eine Erdnuss ist? Wer guckt da doch mal drüber? Ja, oder dass in meinem Peanutbutterglas noch eine Schale ist. Das wäre natürlich fatal. Ja, nee, ich finde Erdnussbedürflich fantastisch. Also, vor allem, wenn man mal so eine Erdnuss plattdrückt, siehst du ja, wie wenig Butter da drin. Wenn man halt die mal Handbuttert, ne? Wenn du die mal melkst, milkst. Ja, stimmt schon. Man merkt das da wirklich sehr wenig ergiebig. Sehr wenig ergiebig. Du brauchst sehr viele Erdnüsse. Und das ist natürlich dann ganz toll, irgendwie dieses Endprodukt zu haben, Erdnussbutter. Ja. Aber ehrlich gesagt bin ich da gerade viel zu ernährungsbewusst, als du sich Erdnussbutter essen würde. Wobei es, glaube ich, gar nicht so ungesund ist. Ja, es hat extrem viele Kalorien, aber es ist halt Butter so, wenn du das einfach ein bisschen butterst. Aber kann man nicht noch Erdnussbutter Butter machen, also kann man den Prozess nicht noch weiter raffinieren? Von der Erdnuss zu Erdnussbutter kann man dann nicht noch sagen, Moment mal, jetzt nimmt man die Erdnussbuttermaschine und anstatt da oben Erdnüsse rein zu tun, tut da oben Erdnussbutter rein und guckt einfach mal, was umdass kommt. Schaut einfach mal. Einfach mal scheiß. Das finde ich sehr gut. Erdnussbutter, Butter, Butter, Butter. Ja, so Erdnussbutter hoch. Und dann kamen so verschiedene Grade. So wie bei Tomatenmarkt. Ist es nicht bei Crunchy, Erdnuss, Butter? Ist Creamy Butter nicht einfach? Oh, jetzt machst du was auch. Erdnuss, Butter, Butter von Crunchy, Erdnuss, Butter? Schwer zu sagen, Schwer zu sagen. Wir haben es nochmal durchgegangen. Wir haben es nochmal durchgegangen. Zum Beispiel wie bei Tomatenmarkt, finde ich, ist es mittlerweile zu weit gegangen. Du stehst im Supermarkt Tomatenmark und hast einmal dreifach konzentriert, siebenfach konzentriert. Du denkst mir, Leute, wie Tomat, ich kann das noch werden? Was ist der Limit? Genug Tomate. Ich bin vom letzten Mal. Ich habe jetzt noch den Geschmack im Mund. Vom letztem Mal. Ja, ich kriege es nicht aus dem Mund raus. Und dann denke ich du vor einem Jahr das letzte Mal Tomatenmark, mir reicht's.
Vor allem, als würde irgendjemand tatsächlich siebenfaches Tomatenmark und dreifaches Tomatenmark unterschiedlich verwenden, wo man sagt, drücken Sie jetzt Tomatenmark rein. Ah, das siebenfache, also muss ich da jetzt noch Wasser rein, macht niemand, man drückt's rein und es ist halt einfach Tomatenentfernung. Es ist so ein bisschen dieses Toilettenpapier-Phänomen, wo man gesagt hat, ah okay, wir bringen Toilettenpapier raus, wir bringen zweilagiges raus, Leute lieben es, wir bringen dreilagiges raus, und Leute sagen, ich lieb's noch mehr, man bringt vierlagiges raus, die Leute können nicht mehr glauben, in welchem Paradies sie gerade leben, und das hat man, glaube ich, versucht auf andere Sachen zu übertragen, dann teilweise. Ich finde den Ansatz ja nicht schlecht, ich mag ja auch den Erdnungsbutter-Ansatz, aber bei Tomaten mag ich... Aber ist die Menschheit nicht zu weit gegangen bei viel lagigem Trätenpapier? Kann man da nicht mal sagen, auch wieder United Nations, kommt mal zusammen, lassen es mal insgesamt wieder auf drei runtergehen. Vier, das war ein Fehler. Ist ja sehr schwer gerade Trätenpapier zu kaufen. Und jetzt habe ich Spanisches nur noch. In meinem Rewe gab es nur noch Spanisches. Ich habe Italienisches. Warum kaufst du Italienisches? Ich glaube, du hast auch Italienisches. Du, ne, ne, ich glaube, du kannst die Sprache nicht auseinanderhalten. Ich hatte nämlich genau das gleiche Gespräch, das hier, mit dem kleinen Tiger. Woppa, ja! Das ist Italienisch. Genau, das dachte ich mir nämlich. Aber vor allem geht es Italien nicht viel schlechter als Deutschland, warum kriegen wir jetzt italienische... Nee, weil wir denen das weggenommen haben, geht's denen deswegen so schlecht? Haben wir denen das Löttenpapier geklaut? Wo ist die Mafia an der Stelle, die sagt, nee, nee, wir kidnappen die Nekarri. Gibt's auch eine deutsche Mafia, die sagt, doch, doch, no, no, no, doch, doch. Das Gespräch, bitte. Aber auf der anderen Seite... Aber da haben wir doch ein Sketch, oder? Die deutsche Mafia. Wir haben Sketch, keine Frage. Das ist ein Sketch. Wir haben halt weder Produktionsteam noch Sender. Ja, aber der Sketch ist ja, dann kannst du halt so einen Report machen, extra, na ja, nicht extra drei, sondern extrem. Extra zwei. Wie ist denn, Express-Aspekte, halt irgendwie sowas, so ein Monitor, Panorama, so eine Sendung. Und dann machst du halt eine Anmoderation, ja, Cosa Nostra, Legendärfilm, aber was viele nicht wissen, auch in Deutschland hat sich die organisierte Kriminalität zusammengekramt. Hier ist unser Beitrag von Magdalena Meierling, Meierling, Meierling-Rödeling, Mats ab und dann kommt der Sketch und dann passieren lustige Dinge. Naja, halt deutsche, deutsche Mafia und dann kannst du halt so die deutschen Klischees machen und das halt kombinieren mit Mafia-Klischees. Das wird halt dann, mein Gott, da wird man dann halt nicht in Beton eingegossen, sondern halt in Brezelteig oder was weiß ich, mein Gott, schreibt doch deinen eigenen Sketch, muss ich jetzt alles machen.
Sehr ruhig in dem Meetingraum.
Ja, drei Minuten, drei Minuten leise Gags dann irgendwie halt so schüchtern. Ich musste gestern, den ganzen Tag habe ich gelacht, weil mir eingefallen ist, dass ich mal Wellensittiche hatte, die die ganze Zeit laut waren und gezählt haben, die ganze Zeit um die gemeckert und hast einfach ein Handtuch genommen und es auf die geschmissen und die haben sofort geschlafen, die haben sofort war Stille und... Gibt's eine klare Dominanz einer Rasse, einer anderen gegenüber, als zu sagen, so, Nacht jetzt! Nacht jetzt! Und du hörst so ein leichtes ... Genau. Scheiße, was ist ... und dann war es nerviger, die schnarchenden Vögel? Dann machst du es wieder hoch und dann ... Ich hab geschlafen, die ganze Nacht, hab getäumt. Hallo, hallo.
Wo ist es, was ist los, wir sind wieder wütend. Ein grosses Gezeter, dann machst du das Tando drauf und sofort stille. Nacht, es herrscht Nacht, kehrt ein. Wie wenn es Werwolf spielt. Oh, ein tolles Partyspiel. Ja, tolles Spiel, aber nervig, weil man als erstes rausfliegt. Peter Maffei. Der Preis für das beste Wortspiel 2020. Sehr trockene Veranstaltung für so einen Preis. Ja, aber auch weil alle auseinandersetzen sehr weit wegen Covid-19. Ja. Florentin Will. Danke, danke, danke, vielen Dank, Dankeschön. Freut mich sehr, den internationalen Wortspielpreis 2020 zu erhalten. Na gut, wenn in dieser Veranstaltung bei keiner Dankes Rede ein Wortspiel gemacht wird, wo auch kein Witz gemacht wird. Ja, es ist eine komplett trockene, ganz normale Haudèvre, ganz normale Plattenspießchen. Nicht die Fischkrawatte, sondern das ist einfach die normale Krawatte. Normale Krawatte. Und ich danke meinen Eltern, jetzt werde ich doch ein bisschen emotional. Ich danke natürlich meinen Eltern, die mich unterstützt haben auf dem Weg. Ich danke Paul, Clara, Fritz, die auch im Publikum sitzen, hallo. Und ja, ich möchte noch die Möglichkeit nutzen, um auf etwas anzusprechen. Es gibt viele Menschen, denen geht es nicht so gut wie uns.
Und deswegen möchte ich an der Stelle nochmal sagen, spendet, spendet, spendet alle Haud'oeuvre, die heute nicht gegessen werden, alle Käsespieße.
Der Moderator hat die ganze Zeit versucht, irgendwie eine lustige Veranstaltung daraus zu machen.
Alle Käsespieße gehen heute, werden heute nach dem Abend an einen guten Zweck gespendet.
Vielen Dank, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend und macht's gut, tschüss. Gut, vielen Dank, so ein bisschen Will. So, Donio Sullivan. Und jetzt kommt... Ja, das war doch was. Und jetzt kommen wir zum, äh, zu dem, echt jetzt, wer gestorben ist im letzten Jahr. Oh mein Gott. Namens ist aber auch so tausende wirklich so ganz dicht gedrängter text tausende wie wir lesen es alle tote alle toten vor warum na ja die wortspielszene ist halt groß jeder Vater der am Herzen gestorben ist der mal irgendwann ein Wortspiel in seinem Leben gemacht hat, ist auch aufgeführt.
Und das ist wirklich so ein Holocaust, weil da war viel zu viele Namen. Und das Lied geht irgendwann auch aus, aber die Liste geht weiter. Man fängt sich ja von vorne an, das Lied. Und Alter, warum haben wir uns von allen Events, die heute Abend waren, für den Internationalen Wortspielpreis entschieden? Warum? Warum? Ich finde, so langweilige Veranstaltungen haben ihren ganz eigenen Charme, finde ich, diese Durchsitz- Veranstaltungen. Irgendwie dieses, es ist so viel Aufwand und so viel kleine Häppchen und Licht für einen Raum von Leuten, die da nicht sein wollen. Die alle genervt sind, ja, ja. Es wurden so viele Brötchen geschmiert. So viel Aufwand, um das negativstmögliche Erlebnis zu machen. Das ist so, niemand will da sein, alle sind froh, wenn es vorbei ist, alle wollen schnell zum Parkplatz, aber irgendwie will der Veranstalter da sein. Ich liebe Parkplätze. Also der Gang raus von sowas, generell abends raus zum Auto zu gehen, zum Fahrrad zu gehen, die Nachtluft, die warme Nachtluft, betet um die Ohren, so ein laues, laues Lüftchen noch. Toll immer, wenn man in den Saal geht, während es noch hell ist, aber wenn die Veranstaltung vorbei ist, ist es schon dunkel und man hat diesen Wechsel von Tag zu Nacht gar nicht mitbekommen. Es ist so schlagartig, es ist so wie die Schönheit eines Sonnenuntergangs in einer Sekunde, zack, du es sofort erwischt. Es ist wie Wellensittich, im Prinzip mit einem Handtuch überangeworfen. Im Grunde ist es eine Wellensittich-Situation. Es ist eine Wellensittich-Situation und dann bist du draußen und dann machst du das Pip-Pip, wenn du ein Auto aufdrückst und das ist doch schön. Bist du so ein Beat-the-Traffic-Typ, der schon früher aufsteht, irgendwie letzter Akt-Theaterstück, Romeo und Julia liegen sich in den Armen und du schon so, sorry, sorry, ich will nicht, dass der ganze Packplatz voll ist, sorry, Entschuldigung. Ich nehme jedes Mal vor, das zu sein und bin es nicht. Ja? Bin immer der, der als letztes noch klatscht. Ich bin auch der, der bis zum letzten, ich schaue mir im Film noch den ganzen Abspann an und denke mir, ich stehe eh im Foyer, weil alle sich drängeln, kann ich auch hierbleiben und mir noch Namen von irgendwie Second-Kostüm-Artist, irgendwie Assistant to Mrs. Portman. Assistant to Guffer, to Mr. Guffer. Das hatte ich mir aber vorgenommen, bei diesem Assistant to Mrs. Portman mal zu lesen, also so bei Black Swan, Assistant to Mrs. Portman, ist das auch dieselbe Person wie beim nächsten Portman-Film? Oder hat die immer andere Assistants? Wie funktioniert das? Aber interessiert dich das speziell bei Natalie Portman? Weil du auf eine weirde, creepy Art an Natalie Portman heran willst? Oder interessiert dich das bei allen Leuten? Es ist visuell eine fantastische Imitation, könnt ihr jetzt nicht sehen. Aber ich, irgendjemand, du kannst ja nicht, du schaust Avengers, kannst ja nicht den Assistant von jedem einzelnen A-List Hollywood-Star merken. Deswegen dachte ich mir, ich merke mir, Portman habe ich nicht gemacht, habe ich wieder vergessen. Und stellt das Studio diese Assistants oder ist es eine persönliche... Was muss man machen, muss man auch nur einen Assistant, wenn Mr. Tietze hat? Ja Man muss Schauspieler sein wahrscheinlich. Ja gut, aber manchmal hat man so Filme mit drei Hauptrollen, aber nur zwei haben Assistant. Du hast einen Assistant to Mr. Corral, Assistant to Mr. Chalamet, aber halt ... Jonah Hill hat keinen bekommen. Keinen Jonah Hill. Jonah Hill hat keinen Assistant. Und man denkt sich, wollte er keinen oder gab's keinen? Schlecht verhandelt oder was? Du hast so viele Fragen. Mehr Fragen über den Abspann als über den Film. Ja, mein Date neben mir sagt, pass auf, du hast vor 20 Minuten einen Arm um mich gelegt und ab dann nur noch Fragen zum Assistant von Jonah Hill gestellt. Ich habe mir das anders vorgestellt. Man braucht jetzt lange Arme in Kinos. Man braucht lange Arme. Bist du denn ein guter Ort für ein erstes Date? Ich glaube nicht. Ich hatte noch nie ein Date im Kino. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Naja, was heißt, ich hatte ein Date im Kino, wo die Frau nicht wusste, dass es ein Date war. Klassiker. Aber im Kino noch angenehmer als überall anders. Also wenn sie zum Candlelight-Dinner kommt und so, du hast ein schönes Restaurant und du hast die Schick gemacht und da steht die Kerze in der Mitte und so. Und dann setzt sie sich hin und sagt, was ist das ein Date? Unangenehm, Kino fällt nicht so auf. Es fällt erst nicht so auf, dass du die Schick gemacht hast, dass du Parfum aufgelegt hast, ist eine angenehme Überraschung in allen Fällen. Ja. Kein kleiner Spaß. Nee, absolut. Du hast so ganz beleidigt geguckt, will man dich gar nicht kennen. Meinerweise lachst du immer bei Witze, aber das hat dich irgendwie getroffen. Wie du mir gerade gesagt hast, dass ich stinke wie ein Aal. Wie ein Iltes, ja. Nee, aber es stimmt schon, Kino ist eine gute Möglichkeit, um Dates zu retten. Wenn dann halt während den Intro-Credits der Kuss nicht klappt, kann man einfach noch durch den Film durchsitzen und hat vielleicht eine gute Zeit. Aber nee, ich glaube, es funktioniert nicht. Aber ich bin der Schlechteste, um Dating-Tipps zu geben, von daher. Ach so, okay. Das ist doof. Wieso brauchst du? Ja, na ja, ich finde jeder da da draußen, auch gerade unsere Zuhörer, glaube ich, können das mal gebrauchen. Jetzt ist ja eh sch... Jetzt gerade ist mal ganz gut, ohne Scheiss, ist das nicht gerade die beste Zeit? Ja, eigentlich war jetzt, jetzt hat es so eine leidenschaftliche, prickelnde Romantik. Man darf es ja nicht sagen. Komm, lass uns treffen, egal, egal, was alle sagen. Man darf es aber auch nicht sagen, aber wir Podcast-Ufo-Hörer, für uns war das doch die beste Zeit aller Zeiten jetzt hier. Wir müssen nicht rausgehen. Wir wollten noch nie rausgehen. Aber wir lieben halt Dates. Gab es nicht tatsächlich bei Tinder die Nachricht, bitte keine Dreier? Nee, bei Tinder stand, dass man sich einfach nicht treffen soll. Man kann ja einfach schreiben. Aber zwei Leute dürfen sich doch immer treffen, oder? Ich dachte nur so, ich denke mir nur so, als ich noch Tinder hatte, wenn ich diese Nachricht bekommen hatte, bitte wegen der aktuellen Corona-Situation, bitte jetzt für ein paar Monate auf Dreier verzichten, hätte ich gedacht, okay, das kriege ich hin. Das ist machbar. Mein Teil für die Welt, für die Gemeinschaft, ja, ich tue meinen Teil, muss ich jetzt jetzt eben verzichten. Schade, da muss ich durch. Das ist schon ein Einschnitt, auf eine Art. Aber es ist eine harte Zeit. Aber da müssen wir für alle durch. Also, Margarete, Lena, ihr müsst euch jetzt entscheiden, make it quick, ich zerbreche so ein Kö, make it quick, nur eine. Stellt euch in die Schlange. Ich habe wieder Dark Knight geschaut. Toll. Fantastisch. Vor allem ein Film, der die ganze Zeit eine Stimmung hat. Also ich habe bei vielen Filmen, wenn man an Filme denkt, hat man ja viele Images im Kopf und viele Schauspieler. 24 pro Sekunde. 24, man hat viele Schauspieler im Kopf, man hat viele Szenen im Kopf und so. Dark Knight habe ich eigentlich nur eine ... Also, der Joker hat irgendwas gemacht, Gordon, Jim Gordon, der Commissioner, Gary Oldman. Der schreit irgendwie ganz laut
und Batman fährt los.
Das ist eigentlich die ganze Stimmung des Films.
Alle sind irgendwie
alle sind überfordert mit der
Situation, Gary Oldman schreit,
Christian Bale setzt sich auf ein Gefährt.
Alles dunkel.
Und es ist ganz dunkel und schön, schön gefilmt,
aber sehr dunkel. Und das ist eigentlich,
das zieht sich die ganze Zeit durch, bis es am Ende vorbei ist. Bis man merkt, oh, Two-Face war auch noch in dem Film. Ah ja, Two-Face. Das habe ich komplett vergessen. Ja, die habe ich ganz vergessen, das stimmt, die ganze Zeit. Jedes Mal, wenn ich in den Film denke, oh geil, Joker, Gordon Ramsay mit seinem Scheinwerfer und dann taucht Two-Face auch in dem Moment. Ach, Two-Face. Ach ja, stimmt, habe ich dann diese Two-Face. Ist Catwoman dran? Nee, im Dreier. Die ist im Dreier. Die ist im Dreier. Nee, die ist im Dreier. Im Zweier. Das ist meine Viewing Experience. Einfach so 50 Prozent gute Zeit, 50 Prozent... Moment mal, war da nicht noch mehr? War da nicht das noch mal drin? Und warum hat Gary Oldman kein Assistant? Ja, stimmt. Der ist bestimmt so einer, der sagt, da kommt jemand, hier ist Margarete, deine Assistentin, und er sagt, nein, ich bin ein Akteur, ich lebe als Gordon und Gordon hat auch keinen Assistenten, bring sie fort. Sitzt sie dann noch rum oder geht die nach Hause, wird die bezahlt, wenn der Schauspieler es ablehnt, wie funktioniert das? Wenn die bezahlt worden wäre, dann hätte sie ein Credit finden. Kann sein, vielleicht ist sie aber auch selber angehende Schauspielerin und will nicht als Assistentin gecreditet werden, weil sonst schadet das ihrer Schauspielkarriere. Dann wäre sie aber Shadow. Wenn sie selber Schauspielerin werden will, dann wäre sie Shadow of Mr. Goldman. Kann auch sein, ja. Oder Lichtdouble. Aber ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich, wenn du Schauspieler werden willst, ist so ein Lichtdubel oder Assistentencredit ganz, ganz schlimm. Wenn dich jemand googelt, so ein Castingagent und sieht, oh, du warst mal Lichtdubel, nee. Nee, warum? Nee, nee, nee. Aber er ist schon ans Licht gewöhnt. Ja, gut, das ist aber das, glaube ich, kleinste Problem. Aber ich war auch schon mal im Filmset, ich habe schon mal Filmset-Erfahrungen gesagt.
Ja, aber Crew ist eine Stufe drunter.
Hä?
Ja, so ist es, ich entscheide das halt zeitlich, ich muss das ja nicht erklären.
So ist es halt.
Können Sie mir das mal erklären?
Nee, das ist halt, nur weil du jetzt einmal am gleichen Catering-Tisch mit Brad Pitch saßt und dich um die Sandwiches gestritten hast,
heisst das ja nicht, dass du in der gleichen Liga spielst.
Nee, Natalie Portman. Ich habe hier Brötchen gebraten und Bananen geschält. Du hast ihr Brötchen gebraten und dann wurdest du gefeuert als die Assistentin. Ja, ich habe es nicht gebacken. Ich wusste nicht genau. Aber ich glaube, dass sie nuschelt auf Kamera. Excuse me, could you please bring me a bread? Was? Speak up a little! I like the bread with a little Just a little bread for me. Nur Brot? Du musst mal was auf den Rippen bekommen. Ruhig, Feuer. You're my assistant, you're supposed to help me not criticize me. So hab ich, oh, so klingt ein handfester Streit mit Natalie Portman. Ja. War nicht höflich. Da gab es ja diese E-Mails mit diesem Autor, die ganz unangenehm waren. Übrig ist Natalie Portman ultra weird. Habe ich nicht gehört. Doch, doch, die hat, das war doch, das habe ich dir, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt. Das war der klassische Natalie-Portman-Fehler. Du bist verliebt in eine Frau, hast aber selber schon eine Frau. Blöd, blöd. Dann sagst du, gut, Scheidung, Schluss machen, gehst du der Frau, die du verliebt bist, sagst so, jetzt bin ich frei, los geht's. Und die Frau sagt, nee, du, ich hab überhaupt kein Interesse an dir. Du hast jetzt einfach schon mit deiner Frau Schluss gemacht. Das ist der Natalie Portman-Fehler. Genau so ist es passiert. Bei Natalie Portman. Dass dieser Autor, der ist ganz berühmt, der hat so einen Dreiernamen. Einer von diesen Dreiern. Du, der Dreier? Dreiernamen. Und der hatte irgendwie so eine E-Mail-Korrespondenz mit Natalie Portman, die ganz unangenehm war, wie sie beide gesagt haben, wie sie die Welt retten irgendwie und sie haben sich so total weltfremd darüber, wie sie jetzt irgendwie die tollen Welt retten, das ist ein ganz merkwürdiger E-Mail-Wechsel und während dieser E-Mail-Korrespondenz hat er sich in sie verliebt, rein durch E-Mail, hat mit seiner Frau Schluss gemacht, wollte sie nicht die Portman, die hat gesagt, nee, lass mal. Und dann stehst du halt zwischen den Stühlen.
Da kannst du nicht zurück und sagen,
du, wegen einer Scheidung.
Ich habe mich so vertan. Habe ich Scheidung gesagt?
Pass auf. Ich wollte, ich meinte,
Abendessen.
Nee, du lass uns das nochmal,
ist jetzt halt schon durch. Scheidung habe ich von, ja,
den Larry David machen dann. Ja, genau.
Du kommst aus dem Department nur mit dem Larry David raus.
Wenn du einfach wieder zur Arbeit gehst, so tun, als wäre die Scheidung nie passiert. Scheidung? Nee, wir haben uns nicht scheiden lassen. Ey, wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Nee. Nö, nö. Möchtest du was aus dem Kühlschrank haben? Nee, willst du auch? Kann ich dir was mitbringen vom Kühlschrank? Durch so einen Aufstosser reden ist es auch perfekt, um so Normalität wieder vorzugaukeln. Möchtest du noch einen Kühlschrank haben? Boah, haben wir noch Erdnussbutter? Hast du schon wieder die Erdnussbutter in den Kühlschrank gestellt? Ich habe doch gesagt, draußen, damit sie cremig bleibt. Direkt einen Streit anfangt, um sich in diesem wohligen Ehegefühl wieder zu finden. Das finde ich super gut. Direkt einen harmlosen Streit anfang. Wahrscheinlich führt man auch kleine Streits, damit man grosse Streits nicht führen muss.
Oh, du meinst, kleine Streits sind aus... Ja, ich würde es einfach leicht verändern. Kompensation. Ja, du hast... Oh, die Ehe läuft schlecht, man liebt sich nicht mehr, die Kinder sind nervig, man will eigentlich Dinge sagen... Trotz allem ist das Marmeladenglas nicht richtig zu. Genau. Nur dass ein bisschen was rausschwappt. Ja, und da ist so ein bisschen Marmelade ausserhalb am Marmeladenglas in dem Gewinde drin gewesen und jetzt klebt das alles zu. Ja, Gott sei Dank, um jetzt nicht über Kinder und Ehe zu Probleme zu sprechen. Und man sagt, Schatz, guck dir mal dieses Marmeladenglas an, fällt dir da was auf dran? Das ist ganz normales Marmeladenglas. Das ist ganz normales Marmeladenglas. Ah, die werden also so geliefert, dass oben alles klebt und man sich komplett die ganze Pfote hier vorklebt. Ja, guck mal, dann machst du hier, nimmst dir ein bisschen Kuchentuch, so, dann machst du es ab und dann kannst Das ist ganz normale, das ist mit dem Ladenglas. Das ist ganz normale, das ist mit dem Ladenglas. Ah, die werden also so geliefert, dass oben alles klebt und man sich komplett die ganze Pfote hier vollklebt. Ja, guck mal, dann nimmst du hier ein bisschen Küchentuch, dann machst du das ab und dann kannst du das alleine ein bisschen, das ist nicht so schwer. Ja, und dann soll ich mir jedes Mal, bevor ich mir Marmeladenbrot schmiere, soll ich jetzt mit einem nassen Küchentuch einkommen oder was? Das ist ja nicht in allen Fällen, das ist ja maximal zwei von zehn Fällen. Ach nee, worüber hatten wir letzte Woche gesprochen, mit dem Aprikosenkompott? Ja, da ist das Feld auch passiert, mein Gott, das ist aber kein großes Thema. Eben, Mücke macht ein Elefanten. Du hast letzte Woche gesagt, du wirst dich anders machen. Du hast dich letzte Woche von mir scheiden lassen. Ja, aber du hast letzte Woche gesagt, bei dem Aprikosenkompott hast du gesagt, du machst es nicht mehr. Und jetzt stehen wir hier mit der Erdbeer-Koffentüre. Ja, du hast auch davor die Woche gesagt, du wirst noch mal scheiden lassen. Jetzt lenkt doch nicht vom Thema ab! Stimmt, sorry, ist unangebracht. Wir reden gerade über Marmelade. Das sollten wir auch vielleicht weiter diskutieren. Guck mal hier, die Nutella. Was ist da draußen dran? Am Nutella-Glas, draußen. Da sich meine Hand, guck nicht mehr, die kann ich jetzt waschen gehen. Schaut euch das mal an! Ja, aber das war Robby, unser Sohn. Ich lass mich von dir scheiden. Nein. Nee, ich lass mich von dir doppelt scheiden. Doppelscheidung, Spiegelscheidung. Spiegelscheidung. Okay. Aber ist mein Jurastudium noch gelohnt? Doppelspiegel. Und da rer so verdammt. Werbung. Boah, ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe das ganze Internet leer geschaut irgendwie. Ich habe alle Serien, alle Filme gesehen, ich habe nichts mehr übrig. Dann kann ich dir empfehlen, wie ich jetzt, den Disney Plus zu holen, denn Disney Plus bietet die ganzen Disney-Klassiker und die Marvel-Filme und hast du nicht gesehen, Pixar, alles und das Highschool Musical Franchise, ja, und ich habe wirklich jetzt angefangen mit der Highschool Musical Serie.
We're all in this together, once we know we're the best. Aber ich finde, das ist eine fantastische Prämisse.
Ich dachte, ich habe erst so aus Spaß reingeguckt, um ehrlich zu sein.
Aber dann ist es die Prämisse, dass in der Schule, wo das gedreht wurde, plötzlich ein Fan als Lehrer dahin kommt, um dann diese Production toll auf die Beine zu stellen, weil sich eine coole Meta-Besprechung des ganzen High School Musical Franchises. Auch das, was das High School Musical Franchise gebraucht hat. Eine Metaperspektive, eine Introperspektive. Auf jeden Fall. Und ich finde es total klasse, ich habe sehr viel Spaß gehabt und ich meine, wir haben alle gerade Zeit. Holt euch Disney Plus.
Wie heißt die Serie? High School Musical, das Musical, die Serie. Ja, schaut rein, bei Disney Plus könnt ihr sieben Tage lang testen und es gibt eine ganze Menge dort zu sehen. Viel Spaß und viel Spaß mit der Folge. Werbung. diese scheiß Westen an, diese orangen Westen, wir sehen nicht mal, wir sehen aus wie so ein Playmobil-Männchen, wir sehen nicht mal aus wie Polizisten, wir haben aber trotzdem, die Uzi dürfen wir trotzdem dabei haben, aber sie werden nie einsetzen, ich glaube so ist es bei Anwälten auch, viel zu hoch, wir machen nochmal Uzi, den Uzi-Kurs machen wir nochmal, wie Modem, Heckler und Koch Test, ja, vernichtende Schadenswirkungen, mäht die Feinde nieder. Können wir am Ton arbeiten? Nee, das habe ich ja vorher gesagt. Also wollen sie tödlich oder wollen sie cool? Nein, weil ich habe jetzt... Tödlich und effizient. Entschuldigung, ich habe eine Lieferung für Peter Mafiosi, 100 Usis will der haben. Der will halt auch, dass es cool rüberkommt. Der will halt, wenn er dann irgendwie mit der ... Was ist daran nicht cool? Es ist halt zu hoch, es ist zu hoch, es klingt wie ein Telefon. Die Leute gucken sich um, greifen an ihre Hüften. Sind Sie das lustig, finden Sie das Uzi lustig, das die tödlichste Uzi, die wir jemals gebaut haben? Ich finde den Ton suboptimal. Wenn ich jetzt auf Sie ziele. Naja, dann denken wir ... Wollen Sie keine Angst? Ja, weil Sie rufen sich an oder was? Wollen Sie sich einwählen in AOL? So, ich habe keine Angst davor, weil es nicht eigentlich reicht. Ich glaube, es reicht. Sorry, Entschuldigung, ich muss kurz ran. Ach, es war gar kein Handy. Oh mein Gott! Was soll das? Okay, ich habe noch eine andere Uzi, die würde vielleicht eher passen. Ja, hör mal rein. Bium. nee, das geht auch nicht, das ist albern
die meisten Leute
unsere Opfer sind relativ alt, die werden das
gar nicht hören, das ist zu tief
das klingt wie so ein
experimentelles Klangbeat
Experiment, oh, das
klingt Einschläfer, das machen wir nicht
nee, nee, das klingt viel zu gelangweilig.
Die Leute, ich höre auf, wegzulaufen.
Sehen Sie die Explosionen, die das erzeugt?
Ja, aber der Ton passt nicht dazu.
Das klingt viel zu langweilig.
Und scheiß, Sie haben ganz problematische Maßstäbe.
Gibt es nicht für die Hohe Uzi so eine Art, nicht wie ein Schalldämpfer, sondern so ein Schalltiefer?
Ja, wir haben einen Schallverstärker. Das ist gut, das ist gut. Ich kann den mal kurz aussetzen. Nee, sorry, ich muss sich kurz ran. Oh, das kann das nicht wahr sein. Ist das der Feuerlamm? Ach, das funktioniert nicht. Das kann man alles auch in den Mafia-Sketch integrieren. Ja, das ist ein großer Sketch-Kosmos. Ein großer Sketch-Kanal. Eine Sketch-Show, nur darüber. Die dann einfach weitergeht. In jedem Sketch wird der Samen gepflanzt für den nächsten Sketch. Und dann geht es weiter. Und immer eine Figur aus dem letzten Sketch kommt in den nächsten rein. Haben die eigentlich schon mal ein Thinkyshot Leaf auf Netflix empfohlen? Ja, bestimmt, oder? Okay, dann können wir es jetzt machen. Dann müssen wir es nicht machen. Tolle Serie, zieht's euch bitte rein. Tolle Comedy. Zieht's euch rein. Sortiert's euch rein. Stopft's euch in die Augen rein. Hast du was sortiert in deiner Wohnung? Hast du irgendwie Bücher nach Farbe sortiert und nach Alphabet? Hast du deinen Kleiderschrank nach Farbe sortiert? Nee, gar nicht. Deine Jogginghosen nach Größe, nach Alter sortiert? Tatsächlich, was mein Problem ist, ich habe für meine Bücher dieses klassische Billy-Regal. Und was einem nicht gesagt wird, ist, dass dieses Billy-Regal eigentlich wirklich ein Machwerk des Teufels ist. Das wird einem nicht gesagt bei Ikea. So, es glaube, da steht da doch. Echt? Da steht Billy und ein Sternchen und da steht drunter, wenn du genau guckst am Sternchen, steht Machwerk des Teufels. Das kann sein, vielleicht habe ich es übersehen. Aber gut, kann sein, weil die Regalfächer sind unterschiedlich groß. Oh, das stimmt nicht. Doch, das stimmt. Wenn man es falsch aufbaut. Nein, das stimmt. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, was du meinst. Ah, ich tue alle meine Bücher zu Thema X in eine Fach. Stellt sich raus, da passt nur die Hälfte rein, weil die andere Hälfte zu gross sind, die Bücher. Und muss ich die woanders reintun? Weil der eine Atlanten die an unterbringen will. Naja, manche Bücher sind lächerlich gross, aber anderes Thema. Und dann verwehrt dir dieses Regal, die nach Themen zu sortieren, weil du eigentlich die Bücher nur noch grösse sortierst. Du hast halt Erster Weltkrieg und Meeresbiologie direkt nebeneinander, einfach nur, weil die gleich gross sind, die Bücher. Und dann hast du die grossen Bücher woanders, das ist albern. Also du bist nicht zufrieden damit. Ich bin nicht zufrieden damit. Möchtest du dir immer ein neues Regal kaufen. Ah, weiß ich nicht. Wie kriege ich das in die Wohnung und dann
weiß ich nicht. Ich denke, ich hatte
ihn nur ein Billigregal und dann dachte mir,
wenn ich zu viele Bücher habe,
dann muss ich alte wegschmeissen. So, kein
Mensch braucht mehr Bücher, als in ein Billigregal
passen, weil ich habe keinen Bock auf
Umzug, dann so riesige Bücherkisten
machen. Kannst du dich für sehr wenig Geld
verkaufen. Gut,
ich weiss nicht weg. Wenn ich hier eins gelernt habe im Podcast, dass man alte Dinge nicht wegschmeißen soll. Ja, aber du kannst ja auch heizen mit Büchern. Bücherverbrennung? Ist das die zweite Bücherverbrennung bei dir im Zimmer? Wenn dir kalt ist, kannst du auch einfach was verbrennen. Ich glaube nicht, dass man das machen sollte. Ich weiss es auch nicht genau. Aber leg einen Teller drunter, dann passt er schon. Dann brennt es nicht alles.
Ich taste mich gerade an mein erstes französisches Buch ran. Beziehungsweise eines habe ich schon gelesen, den kleinen Prinz habe ich gelesen. Und jetzt versuche ich mich so ein ... Wie heißt der kleine Prinz auf Französisch? Le Petit Bronze. Le Petit Bronze. Le Petit Bronze. Ist es im Original ein französisches Buch? Ja, ist es. Ah, okay. Und jetzt versuche ich gerade so ein anspruchsvolles Buch zu lesen, aber ich scheitere immer auf den ersten Seiten. Das heisst, ich habe jetzt so fünf französische Bücher bestellt, die ich alle nicht lesen kann, aber wo ich so wie so ein Schlagzeuger immer in jedes Mal reinguck. Geht schon, nee, geht noch nicht. Wie so ein Pool, der zu kalt ist. Wo du immer so reindippst und sagst, nee. Wie kennt man ja, wenn du vor fünf Pools stehst, die alle unständlich warm sind. Naja, in so einer großen Bavaria-T-Bad oder so. Das kennt man schon, ja, ja. Und dann weisst du nicht genau, oh, das ist das Unterwassermusikbecken, nee. Oder, na gut, sagen wir mal so ein Buffet mit, nee, kennst du Pommesfreunde? Pommesfreunde? Ich auch Französisch. Das ist dieser Pommesladen, wo man ganz viele verschiedene Soßen hat, wo man dann von jeder Soße erstmal ein bisschen was nimmt, dann reindippt und sich dann entscheidet, welche Soße die beste ist und davon dann viel nimmt. So ist es da auch. Und jetzt habe ich verschiedene Bücher, wo ich immer so in verschiedene Welten eintauche. Ich habe erstmal die drei Musketiere, dachte ich mir. Wie heisst das auf Französisch? Les Trois Muscat, weiss ich nicht genau, von Dumas, ist auch ursprünglich auf Französisch, aber ich scheitere immer an den Fachbegriffen, wenn der dann sagt, ja er zog sein Degen, sprang von seinem Pferd, sattelte den Sattel und strifte sich seinen Frieden und denk mir, forget it, alles unbekannt, mehr Verben, ich kann viele Verben, aber ich kann nicht ... Ich kenne bestimmte Werben. Hier eine Liste mit Wörtern, die ich kann. Ah, tatsächlich, es hat sich jemand gemeldet für die Karteikarten-App und wir sind da tatsächlich dran. Nicht im Ernst. Wir sind da dran. Mit einem Hörer bist du zusammen dran? Ja, wir sind dran. Der hat gesagt, ich habe Bock auf ein Projekt und mal gucken, was draus wird. Es gibt ja viele Projekte, die verlaufen im Sande.
Und behalt es noch ein bisschen auf dem Laufenden.
Nee, auf jeden Fall. Es ist die Karteikarten-App, wo man Vokabeln konjugiert lernt.
Also du hast nicht mehr nur Infinitiv kriegst, sondern auch in konjugierten Formen.
Aber du hast ja nicht deine besten Ideen verraten, du wolltest ja nicht im Podcast.
Nee, ich habe noch gute Ideen.
Aber das kannst du ja dann auch machen mit dem.
Ich habe dem Hörer schon meine besseren Ideen verraten, bei allen Ideen, die ich
ihm darüber hinaus noch gesagt habe, meinte er, ist technisch unmöglich. Kannst du die mal sagen? Weil die sind ja technisch unmöglich. Ich wollte es halt so ein bisschen ... Ich hatte die Idee, dass ... Es ist ja oft hilfreich, wenn du ein Wort lernst, dass du siehst, wie das verwendet wird. Weil dann kann man sich direkt vorstellen, weil oft hat man ja so die Wortbedeutung, dann weiß man nicht genau, was es bedeutet. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie er ging, aber wenn man ein Fremdwort benutzt, sag mal ein Fremdwort. Polarität. Genau, Polarität. Und dann sagt der Gegenüber, dann kannst du es mal in einem Satz benutzen, was heißt das? Und dann sagt er, was, zum Beispiel in dem Satz, was bedeutet Polarität? Und das finde ich so schlecht, wenn auf all diesen Karten steht, was bedeutet Petit France. Das ist ja auch immer so bei diesen Spelling Bees, wo die Kinder dann Sachen, da gibt es dann auch mit, give me the definition, okay? I don't know what polarity means. Okay, thank you. Ich kann es in dem Satz benutzen, ich weiß nicht, was Polarität bedeutet. Ja, weil es gibt ja manche Wörter, die haben auch mehrere Bedeutungen. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel hast, keine Ahnung, irgendein Wort heißt lösen. Das kann jetzt heisst Rätsel lösen oder einen Knoten lösen oder sich von einem Menschen lösen. Das kann viele auch, wenn du das Wort so was heisst. So, dann dachte ich mir als Idee, man verbindet diese App komplett mit Netflix, die ist komplett synchronisiert. Und jetzt sage ich dieses Wort lösen und dann klickst du auf das kleine rote N und dann zeigt er dir aus verschiedenen Filmen Szenen, in denen dieses Wort verwendet wird. weil er hat ja Zugriff auf die Subtitles, weiss wo dieses Wort verwendet wird, also das französische Wort für lösen, weiss wo dieses Wort verwendet wird, zeigt dir Szenen aus verschiedenen Filmen und Serien, damit du gleich ein paar Beispiele hast. Wie genial ist das denn? Klappt nicht, klappt wahrscheinlich nicht. Klappt nicht, nee. Klappt nicht, aber ist eine coole Idee, aber ich habe noch viel viel, viel andere. Brauchst du den Kontakt zu Netflix, ne? Weißt du nicht. Ja, die sind schwer heranzukommen irgendwie. Aber ich finde, mittlerweile bauen die auch echt ab. Also irgendwie diese ganzen neuen Produktionen finde ich echt irgendwie. Vor allem, man muss ja echt mal sagen, ich bin ein bisschen auch an diese französische Sache ein bisschen naiv rangegangen, weil ich dachte mir so, die andere Fremdsprache, die ich beherrsche, ist Englisch. Und Englisch schliesst einem wahnsinnig viel. Comedy, tolle Filme, Klassikerbücher, Lieder, Songtexte. Die Franzosen machen nur Scheiße. Exakt, so ist es. Ich dachte mir, okay, dann kann ich französische Filme angucken, ich schau mal auf Netflix, nur Crap, nur Crap. Ziemlich beste Freunde. Ja, ist auch Crap. Das ist alles vor allem ... Dann dieser Film mit diesem Handys, der jetzt auch in Deutschland nachgemacht wurde. Nee, nee, nee, vor allem diese ganz ... Ich habe das Gefühl, französische Filme drehen sich immer um ein Thema, und zwar um Mann-Frau. Also so, was heißt das, man zu sauver, ist das, um Frau zu sein. Ich habe einen Film geguckt von einem Mann, der läuft gegen ein Schild und wacht dann auf und wird behandelt als wäre eine Frau. Oder dann drehen sich die Geschlechterrollen in der Gesellschaft. So, und das ist dann halt mega lustig, halt nicht so. Und dann gibt es einen anderen Film, der ist genau andersrum. Da läuft die Frau irgendwo dagegen und dann wird die Frau so behandelt, als wäre sie ein Mann. Also genau der gleiche Film, nur andersrum. Und es ist immer dasselbe Thema. Und ich verstehe kein Wort, ich verstehe keinen Gag. Welche Serie mir sehr gut gefallen ist, Huge in France. Wie? Huge in France geht um... Huge in France, ja, die ist... Aber auch nicht auf Französisch, sondern auf Englisch. Wobei, es gibt Frankreich gegen den Rest der Welt, so einen Spion beim französischen Geheimdienst, die ist ganz cool, aber die ist auch zu schwer. Er hat zu viele Fachwörter, wie Spion. Ja, ja, das ist ein Problem. Espionage. Sehr gut. Bell, bell, bell, ähm, Dings. Ja, die. Gut gemacht. Ja, ist schwierig, aber ich bin auf jeden Fall dran. Ich habe eine Menge französische Bücher, wo ich den ersten Satz gelesen habe und danach wieder auf den Stapel der Schande gelegt habe. Mal gucken, wo ich hänge. Ich wünsche auf jeden Fall sehr viel Erfolg damit, ich bin mir sicher, dass du das hinkriegst. Hang in there, es ist bei allen Dingen nur eine Motivationsfrage. Ja, aber das hilft ja auch nicht, wenn du sagst, du ist es leicht, so lange du die Motivation aufrechterhalten kannst. Das hilft überhaupt nicht, es ist nur eine Frage, wie motiviert du bist. Du kannst alles schaffen, wenn du es nur intensiv genug willst. Ja, aber mein Problem ist ja, dass ich es eben gerade nicht intensiv wähle. Ja genau, da kann man es lassen. Ich habe schon so in meinem Leben gedacht, jetzt würde ich gerne mal wieder ein bisschen Sport machen und vielleicht ein bisschen abnehmen und so. Und im Kern wusste ich habe die Motivation jetzt für einen Monat, für eine Woche, so dann habe ich es gelassen. Und dann irgendwann hatte ich sie und dann weiss man das auch. Ja, die Frage ist, ob es konstruktiver ist, es dann zu machen, obwohl man weiss, dass man nach drei Tagen aufhört, aber man hat es zumindest drei Tage lang gemacht. Aber vielleicht ist diese Erfahrung insgesamt eher negativ, weil man dann Sport machen mit, oh, Frust, ich höre eh auf, verbindet und dann beim nächsten Mal man weniger motiviert, was man macht. Ich weiss es auch nicht genau. Aber es ist einfach nicht machen, einfach alles erstmal nicht machen. Erstmal zurücklehnen, nichts machen. Erst mal nichts machen und Dinge auf einen zukommen lassen.
Probleme lösen sich von ganz allein.
Ich glaube, das ist eh, also es gibt ja so dieses Sprichwort, ähm, hm.
Ja, habe ich mir so, habe ich jetzt in der Sackgasse mal überlegt. Einen Grube gräbt.
Hält ein Selbstchen ein.
Und da, dass man so sagt, so, weil es gibt ja viele junge Leute, die sagen so, ich weiß nicht, was meine Leidenschaft ist, ich weiß nicht, was mich begeistert, was ich den Rest meines Lebens machen will. Und dann gibt es so ja dieses, ja, tu das, was du machst, wenn du nichts machst. So, wenn du einfach einen Tag frei hast, was machst du dann? Also, in deinem Leben sollte man das machen, was du machst, wenn du prokastinierst? Aha. Also ich klicke mich auf 9Gag an.
Ich klicke Tabs auf und gucke kurz.
Fang bei 9Gag an zu arbeiten. Kann man bei 9Gag einsteigen, weil das wäre dann für den meisten von euch wahrscheinlich der beste Job. Ich glaube, die kriegen täglich 10.000 Bewerbungen und sagen, Leute, wir brauchen zwei Leute, einer guckt die Videos an, einer guckt die GIFs an. Das war's. Das war's. Wahrscheinlich nicht mal. Nicht mal das. Nee, der hat sich ab und zu ein neues Logo.
Der macht den Serverraum ab und zu mal auf und zu, weil er ab und zu lüften muss. Ja, und dann gibt es noch das andere Sprichwort, um zu wissen, was man beruflich machen soll oder so. Angenommen, du würdest halt 10 Millionen Euro im Lotto gewinnen. So geht das Sprichwort? Angenommen, du würdest halt 10 Millionen Euro im Lotto gewinnen. Stell dir mal vor, also jetzt mal grob, je nach Währung, also kommt darauf an, wo du wohnst, stell dir vor, du würdest das Äquivalent von 10 Millionen Euro in der Währung deines Landes gewinnen, was würdest du dann tun, wenn du dir um Geld, also weil du jetzt hast ja genug Geld, was würdest du tun, wenn du dich um Geld nicht sorgen müsstest? Müsstest. Also jetzt nur mal in diesem Szenario gedacht. Und dann sagen die meisten, ja, ich würde in Karibik reisen, na dann wird halt Karibik Reisender. Reisender. Mach halt was mit Reisen. Mach halt was mit Karibik, ja. Und vor allem, das ist halt schwierig, weil das, was man mit Geld machen würde, ist ja nicht das, was man beruflich gerne macht. Also ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich das Äquivalent von 10 Millionen Euro in meiner Landeswährung haben würde, ich würde mir einen Diener einstellen und würde den sagen, gieß mir Tee ein und dann würde ich warten, bis er dabei einen kleinen Fehler macht, irgendwie so die Tee-Kanne. Dann würde ich sagen, Robley, Sie sind gefeuert!
Und dann würde ich mir einenun Diener einstellen und den bei dem kleinsten Fehler auch wieder feuern. Und das würde ich einfach jede Woche neun Diener einstellen und feuern und einstellen und feuern. Wirst du die immer Robley nennen? Immer Robley, Robley the third, Robley the fourth, you chinked the teapot against the tea, a cup of tea, that's enough for me to fire you, leave and never come back. Ja. Robley the sixth, enter. So, und das will ich den ganzen Tag machen und das will ich dann auch beruflich machen, weil das ist das, was ich ja mache, wenn ich so endlich weg bin. Ich würde mir verschiedene Wohnungen kaufen, ich würde mir eine Wohnung in Wien kaufen, eine Wohnung in Berlin, eine schöne Wohnung in Köln und dann würde ich da halt einfach nur die ganze Zeit leben und kochen und Sport. Aha, du willst kochen, also werd doch Koch. Boah, ich hasse dich mit diesem selbstbewussten Vater. Da ist die Kamera, da ist die Kamera, da ist die Kamera. Okay, ich will ja nicht nur kochen, das muss ich ja. Ich habe ja nur gerade gesagt, wo ich es ja auch muss, um zu überleben. Du musst nicht kochen. Natürlich muss man kochen. Nein, man muss nicht kochen. Man kann auch bestellen. Ja, aber du kannst aber einfach irgendwas essen, was man nicht kochen muss. Kaufst dir eine Packung Zwieback und ein Glas Nutella, das ist ja nicht kochen. Ich habe ja Anspruch an mein Leben. Nutella auf Zwieback. Andererseits du habe ich ja nicht aufgegeben, sondern du hast ja kulinarisch teilweise auch einfach, ist dir manchmal auch alles egal. Ja, aber was ist denn die Definition von Kochen? Ist es so, wenn du Koch werden willst? Ich glaube, wir beide haben ganz andere Vorstellungen auch von gutem Leben. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Weil du hast zum Beispiel so etwas wie Möbel, das ich gar nicht für, ne? Null. Das interessiert mich nicht. Ich bin sehr Innenarchitektur interessiert. Ich habe mir ein Bett gekauft bei Ikea und bin bis heute unzufrieden mit diesem Bett. Ich schlafe da seit drei Jahren jeden Tag drin und bin jeden Tag unzufrieden. Aus einem Grund, weil dieses Bett hat an der Kopfseite noch mal so Art Lehne. Ja, ja, das Kopfteil. Ja genau, was eigentlich ganz cool ist, wenn man dann irgendwie einen Film im Bett schauen will oder so, dann kann man sich da anlehnen. Aber das Problem ist, bei dieser Lehne ist unten eine Lücke, also das ist eine Lehne mit so zwei Querbalken und unten ist eine Lücke. Und in diese Lücke wird immer im Laufe der Nacht mein Kopfkissen gestopft. Ich wache auf und mein Kopfkissen ist durch diese Lücke gestopft und liegt hinten am Boden jeden Tag. Und ich wache auf ohne Kopfkissen, Nackenschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, weil ich gegen diese Kante die ganze Gruppe bin. Anscheinend habe ich im Schlaf so einen Kopfdreil, dass ich immer so hochrutsche. Ja, ich rutsche auch hoch. Ich hätte es immer eingeknickt, wenn ich morgens aufwache, bin ich immer eingeknickt am Kopfteil. Und jeden Morgen denke ich mir, das kann doch nicht sein, dieses Scheißbett. Warum baute das Bett denn nicht so, dass da halt keine Lücke ist, damit das Kopfkissen nicht abhauen kann? Design ist ja die Antwort. Ja, und jeden Tag denke ich mir, mein Gott, schiebt er doch irgendwie ein Stück Karton rein oder irgendwie stell da was dahinter, aber wenn du morgens aufwachst, hast du Tatendrang und willst nicht die Probleme von letzter Nacht lösen, sondern willst was anderes machen. Ja, ist es nicht so von Tatendrang, die Probleme zu lösen? Nee, du willst neue Dinge machen. Ach so. Du denkst, das ist ja der, morgens beim Aufwachen ist der Moment, wo das Problem maximal weit entfernt ist. Das stimmt. Es könnte nicht weiter entfernt sein. Ja, es könnte nicht weiter entfernt sein. Deswegen denkst du dir, nee, jetzt mache ich erst mal was anderes. Ich habe gestern ein neues Bett bekommen. Mein Bett kam gestern neu an. Ich habe jetzt ein neues Bett. Riesig? Es ist riesig gross. Jetzt bin ich sehr glücklich. Langsam fügt sich alles in eine neue Wohnung. Wenn du an der linkesten Seite der Matratze liegst, wie oft kannst du dich nach rechts rollen, bis du runterfällst?
Du meinst wie oft eine komplette Umdrehung?
Richtig.
Ja, ich glaube zweimal.
Zwei komplette Rotationen!
1,80 breit. So breit.
Richtig breit.
Was ist dein Durchmesser? Hast du das mal gemessen? Nee, habe ich noch nicht gemessen. Zwei, aber warte mal. Ich bin nicht so breit. Riech breit. Was ist dein Durchmesser? Hast du das mal gemessen? Nee, habe ich noch nicht gemessen. Aber warte mal. Ich bin nicht so breit. Das ist wahnsinnig viel. Vielleicht verschätzt du dich gerade. Ich verstehe dich. Teste das mal. Ich teste das mal und dann würde ich noch mal schreiben. Ich erinnere mich noch, wie wir zusammen im Matratzenladen waren und uns zu zweit auf die Matratze gelegt haben, um zu testen, ob die Matratze gross genug ist für zwei Leute. Damals waren wir noch sehr eng befreundet. Da habe ich mit denen eine Matratze gekauft. Klassische freundschaftliche Dinge getan, wie mal zusammen eine Matratze einkaufen gehen. Das hat mir so leid. Du musstest auch jemanden haben zum Tragen und so. Du bist neu eingezogen. Du bist auch immer mit Wohnen allgemein ein bisschen überfordert. Total. Du wirst auch immer mit Wohnen allgemein ein bisschen überfordert. Und deswegen fand ich es schön. Ich fand es aber merkwürdig, dass du dann kein Interesse hattest, ein Bett zu kaufen, und du wolltest nur die Matratze haben. Alle in diesem Laden haben dir gesagt, kauf dir bitte auch ein Bett, das hat einen Sinn, das hat einen Sinn, das schimmelt da drunter auch. Ja, stimmt. Ja, aber schimmelt es auch, wenn man, na ja, ja, ja, die Antwort ist ja. So, und du hast trotzdem aber irgendwie daran festgehalten. Stimmt, ich hatte lange kein Bett, ist richtig, ja. Dann haben wir zusammen eine Matratze ausgewählt, die uns gefallen hat, die mir gefallen hat. Du hast eine Matratze ausgewählt, die ich am bequemsten fand. Richtig. Sie ist auch bequem bis heute. Ich flipp die immer wieder rum und es stimmt, ich hatte lange keine Matratze, weil tatsächlich in Berlin, ich kam ja von Berlin nach Köln und in Berlin hatte ich statt einem Bett eine zweite Matratze. Gar nicht so schlecht, das Boxspringbettprinzip. Überhaupt nicht schlecht, aber ich dachte mir so, weil das Geile am Bett ist ja nicht das Bett, sondern die Matratze. Also streich doch das Bett, ersetz es durch noch eine Matratze. Das ist wie wenn du Wurstbrot, das Geile am Wurstbrot ist die Wurst, steigt auch das Brot durch Wurst und isst Doppelwurst.
Aber dann entdeckt man, dass gar nicht die Wurst das Geile am Wurstbrot ist.
Richtig, du brauchst die Kombination aus Fett und Kohlenhydraten, du brauchst das Verhältnis 75 zu 25 Prozent.
Ja, weil Fett ist der Geschmacksträger der Kohlenhydrate.
Du brauchst eine Scheibe Wurst, Butter drauf, dann noch eine Scheibe Wurst, Dach aus Wurst. Dann eine Schicht Geschmacksverstärker obendrauf. So ein Kleber. Wie gut. Kannst du mir noch mal kurz den Geschmacksverstärker geben? Einfach so sehr chemisch. Eigentlich muss es gar nicht chemisch aussehen. Bisschen wie auch so mit diesem Marmeladenlaser, die oben diese karrierten Deckel haben. Ja, genau. Das wäre auch schön so auf Geschmacksverstärker. Es war einfach wie so ein Gelee, wie so ein Weiss. So eine Bäuerin drauf irgendwie. So eine Bauernhof. Bio, vegan, alles bio auch gemacht. Einfach so ein Glas Geschmacksverstärker mit so einem Messer, so eine trübe Masse, so eine trübeleitige Schirr-Zielemasse. Widerlich aus, aber toll aufgemacht. Toll aufgemacht. Wie Honig. Ich sehe mir vor, eine furchtbare Konsistenz, zieht Fäden und so. Und dann einfach so, du schmierst es einfach auf ein Brot und es schmeckt halt hart nach Brot. Ja. Halt der Geschmacks von Brot. Es schmeckt unglaublich mal zehn. Das ist das brotigste Brot, das ich je gegessen habe. So, jetzt, I blow your minds, das ist Butter. Nichts anderes ist Butter. Ja, Butter hat einen Eigengeschmack. Bisschen, ja. Butterbrot ist eigentlich auch das perfekte Brot. Ich weiß nicht, warum man da nicht aufgehört hat, weil du hast, wie gesagt, Fettkohlenhydrate, es greift direkt ineinander, es ist ideal. Ja, ist perfekt. Ich finde ja immer so, Butterbrot wird verwendet als langweiliges Essen. So, hey, such dir einen Job, sonst musst du den ganzen Tag Butterbrot essen. Ich so, ich kann den Job skippen und direkt Butterbrot. Ja, vor allem, ja, ich finde, das wurde oft ausgelacht, weil oft musste ich dann früher in so Freundebüchern Lieblingsspeise reinschreiben. Ich habe da liebsten immer belegte Brötchen geschrieben. Weil ich finde, es gibt nichts besseres als so ein schönes Brötchen mit Butter, Käse drauf oder Schinken oder sowas. Einfach ein belegtes Brötchen. Mir läuft das Wasser im Mund zusammen. Ich kann mir gerade nichts schöneres vorstellen als ein belegtes Brötchen. Tatsächlich, was ich nicht verstehen kann, sind Leute, die dann dann noch irgendwie so ein Gürkchen oder eine Tomate drauf tun. Skip the Gurke, skip the mozzarella weg und lass die fucking Remoulade weg. Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen. Wann hat die Remoulade angefangen in seinem Leben, einzig dringend so aggressiv? Wenn mir jemand ein Salami-Brot gibt mit Gürkchen drauf, würde ich sagen, schmeiss es weg, du hast es ruiniert. Ich nehme das Brötchen und klatschest dem so ins Gesicht dann immer. Salami braucht keinen Sidekick. Salami ist einfach Stand-up, 90 Minuten, Eddie Izzard ballern. Da braucht nicht irgendwie noch so ein Sidekick. Zu Salami? Nein. Aber ich bin jetzt auf YouTube ein bisschen hängen geblieben auf diesen, und die sind anscheinend extrem beliebt beliebt diese Videos dieses Amerikaner in Deutschland reden drüber, was sie da besonders finden an der deutschen Kultur und halt dann auch andersrum und so und Amerikanerinnen, die mal in Deutschland gelebt hat, das schaut man sich einfach gerne an. Ich finde es auch spannend. Man lernt auch viel über sich selbst, was man hier als E-Geme akzeptiert, was man da gar nicht selbstverständlich ist. Und auch so dieses. Mettbrötchen ist doch das lustigste der Welt, wenn Amerikaner Mettbrötchen essen. Genau, erst mal dieser Mindblow. Es ist unglaublich, es ist rohes, aber auch für mich, es stimmt, man isst rohes Schweinefleisch. Und das würde man niemals tun, aber natürlich mit Mett. Und auch so diese, ich teste deutsche Süßigkeiten und dann einfach so ein Amerikaner von einem Schokokuss und denkt sich, what the fuck ist das? Und dann denkst du dir, ja, was ist das eigentlich? Also wie würde ich darauf reagieren, wenn ich das nicht seit Kindheit kennen würde? Es ist einfach Schnee mit Schokoguss auf einer Waffel, so was ist das? Aber am Ende sagen die, das ist eigentlich immer ganz geil. Und tatsächlich, was diese eine, die in Deutschland gewohnt hat, dann wieder nach Amerika gezogen hat, hat gesagt, was sie am meisten vermisst, sind beim Bäcker, dass man sich so Brötchen, belegte Brötchen kaufen kann.
Ja, und von allen Dingen in Deutschland hat sie gesagt, weil das gibt es in Amerika anscheinend gar nicht, da gibt es keine Stuhlenkultur, aber in Deutschland halt kannst du bei jedem Bäcker und die und dann die sind die sehen ja eigentlich geil aus, das fällt einem gar nicht auf so ein bisschen mit jetzt übersprechen wir ein bisschen, aber Salat zählt nicht, mit ein bisschen Salat aufgemacht und dann so schön knuspriges Brötchen mit schönem Butter und Schinkenkäse. Brötchen oder so, das ist auch so schön. Ja, es ist ein kleines Brot. Ja. Aber es ist nicht wirklich ein kleines Brot, es ist eine andere Art von Brot. Es hat mir diese Brotform geschenkt. Ja, was ich aber auch gerne hätte, wäre ein kleiner Leib Brot. Ich habe auch nichts Lieberes als hier, ich gehe gerne in Köln zur Zeit für Brot. Ich liebe Zeit für Brot. Man kann sehen, was die machen. Ich weiß, was das ist. Das ist ganz toll, die machen auch diese perfekten Zimtschnecken. Oh mein Gott! Und da kannst du dieses ganz tolles, das Lieblingsbrot, Kartoffelkrustenbrot kaufen. Das ist einfach die perf hat die perfekte Grösse, weil man es auch schafft, irgendwie zu zweit oder alleine und das ist halt super, es ist schön rund, es ist eine sehr befriedigende Form. Du kannst es gut transportieren, es ist nicht wirklich viel zu groß, aber so ein ganzes Leib Brot zu kaufen, hat sowas, und der sieht so comic-haft aus. Der sieht so aus, wie Vicky und die starken Mänger finden so eine Vorratslage und kauft und sehen Brot mit. Er sieht aus wie das Emoji für Brot. Ja. Er sieht aus wie das perfekte Brot. Genau. Ja. Und das ist sehr befriedigend, das zu essen. Aber dann Scheiben? Dann habe ich ein gutes Brotmesser natürlich, das ist Key für jede gute Küche, und dann schön Scheiben. Dann kannst du überlegen, mit Butter und Knoblauch beschmieren, vielleicht auf den Grill legen. Wow. Du und dein Grill, ey. Ich habe nur einen Grill, ich habe keine Küche im Grill. Das ist wie ich zwei Jahre lang nur einen Wasserkocher hatte und ich bin einfach, habe mich verbrüdert mit diesem Wasserkocher, wir haben Blutsfreundschaft geschworen, weil ich alles in diesem Wasser, ich habe am Ende Wiener in dem Wurst, alles in dem Wasserkocher gemacht, ich habe wirklich Spaghetti, ich habe auch mal Milch reingemacht, natürlich halt jeder mal gemacht, Milch im Wasserkocher, Riesenkatastrophe, aber ich konnte mir keinen neuen leisten und musste alles sauber. Hast du auch Honig reingemacht? Honig? Nee. Kein Honig kochen? Ich konnte lange keinen, ich war letztens, ich möchte einen neuen Begriff prägen, und zwar das Knobloch. Knoblauch, Knoblauch, was ist das Knoblauch? Ich hatte, und das geht mit allem, nicht nur mit Knoblauch, aber bei mir war es konkret Knoblauch, deswegen möchte ich es danach benennen. Ich hatte, ich liebe Knoblauch, ich auch, aber ich hatte immer das Problem, dass ich immer am Einkaufen war und ich wusste, wie viel Knoblauch ich noch zu Hause habe, und dann habe ich immer eine neue Packung Knoblauch gekauft und dann hatte ich viel zu viel Knoblauch zu Hause. Irgendwann hat sich das gestapelt und irgendwann wurde der alt und hat angefangen, schlecht zu werden. Und dann habe ich irgendwann, wollte ich Knoblauch benutzen für so Alio-Olio-Knoblauch-Spaghetti und habe diese Knoblauchzehe aufgemacht und die war halt faul. Und die riecht... die riecht extrem intensiv, aber halt widerlich. Und das Problem an ja faulen Sachen ist, sie riecht wie das, was man kennt, mit so einer faulen Note drin. With a twist. Ja, with a twist. Und das Problem ist dann, und das glaube ich geht vielen so, wenn man sowas mal verfault, gesehen und gerochen hat, kann man es nicht mehr essen Oh nein, hast du Knoblauch versaut? Du bist in Knoblauch gefallen? Exakt, das ist das Knoblauch. Das ist die Zeit, in der man etwas, was man liebt, nicht essen kann, weil man es verfault hat. Und ich war tapfer. Ich habe mich da durchgekämpft. Ich habe gesagt, nein, du ekelst dich jetzt vor Knoblauch, aber du musst da jetzt durch! Und ich habe mich dazu gezwungen, weitere frische Knoblauchzehen zu essen, um so schnell wie es geht durchs Knoblauch zu gehen. Was machen Sie da? Ich muss auch direkt wieder Skifahren gehen, wenn man mich verletzt hat, um keine Angst umzukommen. Genau, genau das ist es. So, das ist nämlich zum Beispiel auch so, wenn man sich übergibt, wenn man irgendwas isst. Ich hatte das lange bei Baguettes, bei diesen Aufback-Baguettes. Oh, Tequila. Ja, und da muss, das ist auch eine Art von Knobloch und du musst da durchkämpfen. Du darfst es nicht der Zeit überlassen, weil ansonsten kann es sein, dass du das nie wieder isst. Ich habe bis heute Probleme mit diesen Aufback-Baguettes, mit diesen, also diesen Pizzabaguette-Dingern. Ach so, gegöbelt? Davon habe ich mich übergeben, habe ich mich gebrochen. Davon hast du gebrochen? Habe ich gegöbelt. Und ganz merkwürdig, weil es ist ja im Grunde nicht etwas anderes als Pizza, aber irgendwie diese Form hat sich in meinem dummen Gehirn abgespeichert, als hieß das nicht. Roulade? Kohlroulade. Ja. Davon musste ich immer brechen. Uff. Ja, und dann habe ich das jetzt erst mal sein gelassen. Ich glaube, ich habe mich seit locker zehn Jahren nicht mehr übergeben, wirklich ewig lang nicht mehr. Nee, ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, es gibt Leute, bei denen ist das so ein monatliches Ding, aber wirklich, er hat wahrscheinlich auch viel mit Alkohol zu tun, wenn du kein Alkohol trinkst, dann ist das bis da ein bisschen weiter weg. Nee, aber auch dann nicht eigentlich. Sollte man sich ja irgendwann auch auskennen.
Wie dem auch sei, göbelt nicht so viel,
brecht nicht so viel.
Allgemein. Ganz, ganz viel Mut fürs Knoblauch.
Mut in der Zeit fürs Knoblauch. Geht er durch.
Ansonsten wünschen wir euch beiden eine
ganz, ganz fantastische
kommende Woche. Haut rein, macht's gut.
Die hat bestimmt viel Empetto für euch.
Wir sagen tschau und wir heben ab,
wie jedes Mal. Macht's gut, tschau!
It's a world,
Entschuldigung, it's a world
bird production.